고전적 정보가 특수한 경우로 본질적으로 나타나요. 이제 그게 어떻게 작동하는지 설명할게요.
구체적으로, 확률 상태가 밀도 행렬로 어떻게 표현될 수 있는지 살펴볼 거예요.
고전적 상태부터 시작해 볼게요. 간단한
예시부터 시작할게요. qubit의 0과 1 표준 기저 상태의 밀도 행렬 표현이 여기 있어요.
이 상태들을 고전적 상태 0과 1에 연관시키면, 이 밀도 행렬들이 그 상태들을 나타낸다고 생각할 수 있어요.
아주 간단하고, 쉽게 일반화할 수 있어요.
고전적 상태 집합이 시그마인 시스템이 있다면, 고전적 상태 a는 밀도 행렬 |a⟩⟨a|로 표현되거나
연관돼요. 그 행렬은 고전적 상태 a에 해당하는 행과 열의 대각 원소에 1이 하나 있고,
다른 모든 원소는 0이에요. 확률 상태는 이런 형태의 행렬들의 볼록 조합으로 표현되는데,
이건 밀도 행렬과 작동 방식에 대해 알고 있는 것, 즉 밀도 행렬의 볼록 조합이 무작위 또는
확률적 양자 상태 선택을 나타낸다는 사실을 고려하면 자연스러운 거예요. 예를 들어, 고전적 상태 집합이 어떤 양의 정수 n에 대해 0부터 n-1까지의 정수를 포함하는
시스템 X가 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
물론 고전적 상태 집합이 이 형태라고 가정해도 일반성을 거의 잃지 않아요. 다른 고전적 상태 집합이 있다면
단순히 고전적 상태의 이름을 이렇게 바꾸면 돼요. 그리고 고전적 상태 집합이 이런 형태라고 가정하면 꽤 편리해요.
주로 벡터와 행렬 측면에서 명시적으로 쓰기가 더 쉬워지거든요.
시스템 X의 확률 상태가 일반적인 방식으로 확률 벡터로 표현된다고 가정하면,
이 확률 상태를 밀도 행렬과 연관시킬 수 있어요.
화면에 나타난 것처럼요. 서로 다른 고전적 상태에 해당하는 밀도 행렬들의 가중 평균을 취하면,
대각 밀도 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 특히 이 행렬의 대각선에 확률들이 나타나고,
다른 모든 원소는 0이에요. 물론 이건 밀도 행렬이에요.
그게 사실이어야 한다고 예상하지만, 직접적으로도 추론할 수 있어요. 에르미트 행렬이고, 확률이 합산되어 1이 되기 때문에 트레이스가 1이에요.
대각 행렬의 경우 고유값이 대각 원소이고,
이들은 확률이기 때문에 모두 음이 아니에요. 또한 모든 비대각 원소가 0인 모든 대각 밀도 행렬은
이런 형태여야 함을 알 수 있어요. 간단히 말하면,
확률 상태는 대각 밀도 행렬과 연관될 수 있어요. 이건 수업 초반에 제가 언급한 밀도 행렬 원소들의
비공식적 해석과 일치한다는 점도 알아두세요. 특히 양자 중첩이 없어요.
기본적으로 고전적인 무작위성일 뿐이고, 그에 따라 모든 비대각 원소가 0이에요.
이 시리즈 앞부분에서 스펙트럼 정리에 대해 이야기했는데, 위상 추정의 맥락에서
유니터리 행렬에 대해 구체적으로 다뤘어요. 스펙트럼 정리는 그것보다 더 일반적이에요.
즉, 유니터리 행렬보다 더 넓은 범위의 행렬에 대해 무언가를 알려줘요.
특히, 모든 에르미트 행렬과 유니터리 행렬을 포함하는 정규 행렬이라는 행렬 클래스에 적용돼요.
이제 이 정리를 다르게 진술해 볼 거예요. 이번에는 양의 반정치 행렬에만 집중해서,
밀도 행렬에 대해 아주 흥미롭고 매우 중요한 것을 알려준다는 걸 보게 될 거예요.
P가 임의의 양의 반정치 행렬이라고 가정해 볼게요. 이건 트레이스가 1인 밀도 행렬을 포함해요.
P는 양의 반정치이므로 n×n의 정방 행렬이어야 해요. 그 n을 참조해야 하니까 n을
적절하게 선택하거나, 다시 말해 P가 n×n이라고 가정해요. 이 경우 정리가 알려주는 건,
ψ₀부터 ψₙ₋₁까지 이름 붙인 정규 직교 기저 벡터가 존재해야 하고, 음이 아닌 실수
λ₀부터 λₙ₋₁까지도 존재해서 P를 화면에 나타난 것처럼 표현할 수 있다는 거예요.
말로 표현하면, 각 λₖ에 |ψₖ⟩⟨ψₖ|를 곱하고 k를 0부터 n-1까지 합산하면 P를 얻어요.
이것을 P의 스펙트럼 분해라고 해요. 각 λₖ는 반드시 P의 고유값이고,
각 ψₖ는 그 고유값에 해당하는 P의 단위 고유 벡터예요.
위상 추정에 관한 7번 수업을 다시 보면, 유니터리 행렬에 대한 유사한 정리를 찾을 수 있어요.
거기서 고유값은 음이 아닌 실수가 아니라 단위원 위의 복소수예요. 하지만 나머지는 같은 아이디어예요.
이것들은 사실 스펙트럼 정리라고 하는 더 일반적인 정리의 두 가지 특수한 경우예요.
모든 행렬에 대해 작동하지는 않아요. 행렬이 켤레 전치와 교환 가능해야 해요.
그게 행렬이 정규 행렬이라는 의미예요. 하지만 실제로 유니터리 행렬과 양의 반정치 행렬 모두에 대해
항상 성립해요. 더 일반적으로 에르미트 행렬에서는 실수 고유값은 항상 있지만 반드시 음이 아닌 건 아니에요.
그래서 양의 반정치 행렬에 대한 스펙트럼 정리를 진술했고,
이제 그게 밀도 행렬에 대해 무엇을 알려주는지 살펴볼게요.
이게 알려주는 건, 임의의 n×n 밀도 행렬에 대해 항상 그 행렬을 n개의 순수 상태의 볼록
조합으로 표현할 수 있다는 거예요. 더욱이 그 n개의 순수 상태를
직교하게 선택할 수 있어요. 이건 정리와 선형 대수의 기본 사실, 즉 임의의 행렬의 고유값의 합이 항상 그 행렬의 트레이스와 같다는 것으로부터 꽤 직접적으로 따라나와요.
다시 말해, 우리가 실제로 하는 건 고유값의 이름을 p₀부터 pₙ₋₁까지 바꾸고,
그 고유값들을 n차원 벡터로 모으면 반드시 확률 벡터가 된다는 걸 관찰하는 거예요.
모두 음이 아니어야 하고, 합이 ρ의 트레이스와 같아야 하는데, ρ가 밀도 행렬이니까 그게 1이에요.
이건 꽤 간단하지만, 개념적으로는 정말 근본적이에요. 이게 알려주는 건, 아무리 복잡해 보여도 모든 밀도 행렬은
우리가 이야기하는 시스템의 정규 직교 기저를 먼저 선택하고,
그 다음 어떤 확률에 따라 그 기저에서 무작위로 양자 상태를 선택해서 얻을 수 있다는 거예요.